ابدا معك عبد القادر باتت المعلومات
متوفره اكثر حول المستهدفين في عمليه
المزه مريم دعيني افرق حقيقه بين مصطلحين
اثنين في هذه الضربه اذا ما صدقت هذه
المعلومات التي يتناولها الاعلام الايراني
عن مقتل مسؤول الاستخبارات في في فيلق
القدس في الحرس الثوري العميد الحاج صادق
او العميد يوسف اميد زاده المشهور بالحاج
صادق نحن لا نتحدث حقيقه عن مقتل مستشار
ايراني على الاراضي السوريه نحن نتحدث عن
مقتل مسؤول كبير في الحرس الثوري على
الاراضي السوريه هذا تفريق مهم حقيقه لان
مصطلح مستشار هنا لا ينطبق على العميد
الحاج صادق هذا الرجل هو ربما مسؤول وحده
الاستخبارات الاهم في الحرس الثوري وهي
وحده الاستخبارات في فيلق القدس وهو ربما
يوصف بالصندوق الاسود عندما نتحدث عن
استخبارات محور المقاومه ككل ربما
في المنطقه نائب الرجل كذلك اذا ما صدقت
المعلومات على انه تم اغتياله ايضا في هذه
الغاره الاسرائيليه كذلك نحن نتحدث عن
مسؤول استخباراتي ايراني يقتل بفعل
اسرائيلي على الاراضي السوريه الموضوع
تجاوز الحديث عن مستشارين عسكريين على
الارض السوريه هذا محدد مهم حقيقه وهذا
تفريق مهم لكي نفهم كيف تتعاطى ايران مع
هذه الغاره على الاراضي السوريه في النقطه
الثانيه اذا ما صدقت هذه المعلومات ويبدو
بانها مرجحه جدا لان الاعلام الايراني
يكون حذر حقيقه عندما يتعامل مع اسماء
وازنه من هذا الموضوع نحن نتحدث عن ضربه
اسرائيليه وازنه حقيقه على الاراضي
السوريه مستهدفه لاهم وحده استخبارات في
الحرس الثوري في فيلق القدس لذلك يمكن ان
نقول بانها ضربه وازنه الاعلام الايراني
يتحدث هنا عن ضربه مؤلمه اذا ما صدقت هذه
الاخبار قبل قليل كنت ربما استمع الى احد
اشهر المحللين السياسيين الامنيين هنا على
احدى القنوات الايرانيه يقول صراحه بان
الذهاب الى الحرب بسقف ربما غير مفتوح
وبسقف غامر ربما يكون احد ادوات منع هذه
الحرب بالمعنى الاقليمي هذا كلام جديد
حقيقه على الاعلام الايراني كلام ربما
يصدر من محللين معروفين بالمعنى الامني
هنا في داخل البلاد كيف ستتصرف ايران
الرسميه حتى الان لم نسمع اي بيان حقيقه
مريم من الحرس الثوري يؤكد هذه المعلومات
ربما او يطرح دعيني اقول ارهاصات اوليه
للتعامل مع هذا الموضوع ايضا في الاعلام
الايراني هناك من يوازن بين الضربات التي
تلقتها اسرائيل ربما او المكان الذي تحدثت
عنه ايران عندما ضربت اربيل بانه مكان
ومبنى تابع للموساد الاسرائيلي وبين هذه
الضربه حتى ان الاعلام الايراني يكشف عن
بعض الاسماء ويقول بانهم كانوا ضباط كبار
في الموساد يدورون عمليات الموساد بما
يعرف بمنطقه شرق المتوسط ربما بان الحديث
الان عن خرق الخطوط الحمراء بات ترف حقيقه
لاننا نتحدث عن مسؤول كبير جدا في الحرس
الثوري اذا ما صدقت المعلومات ومسؤول مهم
جدا عندما نتحدث عن محور المقاومه هذه
الضربات حقيقه مريم بهذه الطريقه الموجعه
هل ستدفع ايران لان تذهب ربما خارج السقف
الاستراتيجي الذي تتحدث عنه بانها لا تريد
حرب مفتوحه في الاقليم هل ستدخل ايران
مريم حلبه ملاكمه ربما بالمعنى الامني
والعسكري معلنه على مساحات الاقليم مع
اسرائيل هذا غير مستبعد خاصه عندما نتحدث
عن شخصيه مثل العميد الحاج صادق في الحرس
الثوري شخصيه وازنه شخصيه صف اول بالدرجه
الاولى باتت الساحه السوريه حقيقه ساحه
مؤلمه ربما للتواجد الايراني صحيح ولكنها
ساحه استراتيجيه البعض هنا في ايران بدا
الحديث على ان هل الساحه السوريه مخترقه
بهذا المستوى للوصول الى شخصيات بهذا
الحجم هذا في تحليل طبعا الامور مفتوحه
حقيقه مريم على مصراعيها اذا ما اعلن
الحرس الثوري بشكل واضح وصريح بان الغاره
ادت الى اغتيال العميد يوسف اميد زاده
المعروف بالحاج صادق ستكون ايران ربما
معنيه بتعاطي مختلف عن كل ما سمعناه حتى
الان من عمليات اغتيال اسرائيليه لقاده في
الحرس الثوري سواء على الاراضي السوريه او
خارج الاراضي السوريه كذلك